here we are in the middle of june and
nothing is as it should be
students who are graduating are quietly
moving on the traditional celebrations
a thing of the past and the last few
months of education have been
less than ideal since the beginning of
the pandemic the united nations has
monitored school closures around the
world
at the peak more than 91 percent of the
world students
were out of class that's close to 1.6
billion children some places have begun
reopening schools just over 20 european
countries for example
have allowed kids back in class but with
restrictions
and there have been setbacks in france
within days of reopening there were
outbreaks and several schools
had to close again after 70 students and
staff tested positive
for covid19 for those still open
it hasn't been business as usual by any
means there are smaller classes
cafeterias are closed lockers are out of
use libraries
off-limits here in north america most
states and provinces have been cautious
there have been limited reopenings in a
handful of american states
and in canada several provinces have
welcomed students and teachers back but
it's not business as usual in quebec one
of the first jurisdictions on the
continent to reopen classes
it wasn't province-wide in the montreal
metropolitan area the region
hit hardest by covid19 schools are still
closed
where they are open we wanted to see how
things have gone
our mike armstrong went to howick
elementary just an
hour outside montreal getting back into
class
has been a learning experience for
everyone and some of the lessons could
be applied across canada
when parents pull up and drop their kids
off things at howick elementary school
look
normal you notice what's not normal when
the buses pull up
basically the numbers instead of 30 or
40 kids this bus drops off
four classes are optional and a lot of
parents have decided to keep their kids
home
for those who did come back this last
part of the year
is sort of a dry run for the fall the
kids that are here now
are going to be better off in september
than the ones that are just coming
straight back
that's what i think that's kind of what
we thought about it
howick elementary would normally have
170 students kindergarten to grade six
right now it has just 40 students so
it is a challenge rob butters heads the
new frontiers school board
he says attendance board wide is running
at about 29 percent
there's been various reasons why parents
have chosen to keep the children
home the first one is absolutely there's
still the fear of catching
the virus no question about it now when
the school reopened there were a ton of
changes
one of them limiting access while
students are in class journalists aren't
allowed in the building
they did let us in after school so it's
a little strange but principal melanie
primo agreed to take one of our small
cameras inside to show us how things are
going hold on i'll even
i'll even get the door for you
the first thing you notice is the
physical distancing the desks are far
apart and that's where kids spend most
of their time
in fact to cut down on possible
transmission of kovid19
a lot of the school is closed the
lunchroom is not being used the library
is not being used
our gymnasium is not really used as a
gymnasium
our outside play structures
can't be used there are new markings on
the floors of the hallways everyone's
supposed to stay to the right
and to keep two meters from the people
in front of them which
leads to the question can you even get
kids to physically distance
uh i'd say 95 of the time yes but
we're human and sometimes we cross paths
and we back up i'd say the biggest
challenges outside
when they're playing one of my phys ed
teachers
actually organizes games for them
outside to sort of
teach them how to play social distance
style
no it's your recess the staff is
adapting and some of it's a little
strange the
soccer balls that usually get cleaned
once a year are now sanitized
several times a day and there's
also a new activity students are
bringing their personal bikes to school
for gym class
the bikes it's just to have another
activity
have them able to use some equipment
because it's hard to land out equipment
unless we're washing it every single
time
some quebec schools that reopened have
had setbacks
in the first three weeks close to 50
students tested positive and
more than 30 staff that despite all the
preventative measures
the new frontiers board hasn't had a
student test positive
they've been a little less lucky on the
staff side i believe we've had four
staff members who have been tested
since we came back in may 11th and i
believe only one of them
was positive and that person is fine now
we've been we've been fortunate as
a school board to have not had a high
number of of cases that we've had
to involve testing but you watch for
that i would imagine we certainly daily
i mean that's
one of the roles big roles of the
principal and the staff here at the
school
and we urge parents and children to not
come to school if you're not feeling
well
when the province made the move to
reopen schools the argument was that
while there was a danger
it was outweighed by the potential
damage kids with learning difficulties
need to be monitored
and for others sitting at home for
months mental health can be an issue
but the partial return with smaller
classes has let
schools find what works and what doesn't
the maximum number of students in a
class was supposed to be 15
they found 11 is pretty much the maximum
if you want to let kids stand up
the school also now has an indoor and an
outdoor to help with social
distancing and they're working on new
ways to send homework and notes
home with students we don't even know if
the kids are going to be able to bring
things
things home so we've decided as a staff
to not by agendas the big issue right
now is communication
inside the school across the school
board and across the country
quebec is being watched and sharing its
experiences
some experts predict this pandemic will
lead to major changes in education
everything from the rethinking of the
school calendar to new ways of teaching
the new frontiers board barely did any
online instruction before this
now it's something new it brings to the
table going forward
and it's sticking around i think will be
a better
system with the ability to have blended
learning
time will tell i think moving forward
learning might never be the same i think
it will be better
[Music]